(soft classical instrumental music)
- So its 11 o'clock.
We are now almost driving around one hour
for Puffin patrol security thing.
There's one, there's one, there's one.
Be careful.
Yes, we got one.
Elfie, hand me the net.
(loud horn honking)
Come here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Got it.
- My goodness.
You are drama queen.
Yes, everything is fine.
Now you're happy.
- [Elfie] Sweetheart, yes.
(soft instrumental music)
- Newfoundland, the place and the land
and the ocean is just as
much a character in our lives
as your brother or sister.
You know, we've always been that way
because we're isolated; we're an island.
Everything here is so interconnected
and people feel that because they have to.
It was the only way they could survive.
(loud motor revving)
- Less than two kilometers
from the coastlines
of Witless Bay is the Witless
Bay Ecological Reserve.
It's a group of islands that's spread out
from the Witless Bay region,
and they're home to the Atlantic Puffin,
Newfoundland's iconic bird.
There's over 600,000 pairs
of Puffins on these islands.
They mate every year.
They go to sea for four years,
and when they come back
they keep coming here.
There's records showing
that we have Puffins
that are up to 20 and 30 years old there,
and they come to the same burrows.
So it's really important
that this ecological
reserve was established
to protect these birds.
If you look around the community now,
they advertise it's the
home of the Atlantic Puffin
and some of their facilities
are named after a Puffin,
the school mascot is a Puffin.
So it's something that
people are proud of.
Everybody can resonate with them.
- The Puffin generates a
lot of revenue in tourism
in Newfoundland and
especially in this local area
and it creates a lot of jobs.
- It's a big icon for
tourism in Newfoundland.
A Puffin, it's our provincial bird.
So we've really got to look after them.
- It has sort of always been a thing.
We would see the birds
squat all over the road
and different things and
we just knew, obviously,
they were confused.
But we didn't know anything about that
until into the 2000s.
That's when we started to
learn what the problem was.
It could of been many people
who came into our town
and started the Puffin patrol.
And there would of been resistance
because it would of been
the whole "your an outsider,
"how are you telling us what to do?"
But this is unique because it was Juergen.
- And you want to look
me in the camera right?
- Me.
- No, you can look...
- Oh, to you, okay good, okay that's good.
- His presence is vast,
and it's very open.
Everybody knows Juergen.
- It's beautiful, yeah.
When I go to the post office or the shop,
they say, hey Puffin man, and
I think it's a compliment.
I wouldn't call me a real environmentalist
because I know people
who do this do much more
than what I'm doing.
But we just taking care as I learned it.
I think it's normal to
do things like this.
When you see something, it's
wrong, try to change it.
- I met Juergen a long time ago.
He was in filmmaking and he had quite
an array of movie stars.
He's his own character.
He beats his own drum.
- And I love this air.
It's like champagne
It's so wonderful here.
- I'm so grateful, and
we're all so grateful
that he came in, he saw the situation
and people just then
stirred the common gator
and just feel good about doing something
for their community.
- I want to know tonight,
it's Puffin patrol again.
Are you ready?
It was in August and our family,
we watched on the road dead little birds.
- [Reporter] During the day Juergen
often finds other Puffins
on the Witless Bay roads
who are not so lucky.
- Every year hundreds of young Puffins,
those birds with colorful beaks,
lose their way in the
waters off Newfoundland
and Labrador ending up
on a wing in a prayer.
- [Man] The little Puffins
have been getting lost in town.
- So I was asking people
here around, what is it?
And they told me don't touch it,
their poison has been always there.
But I thought, something is wrong.
What could it be?
And then you find out that this
little dead bird on the road
are little Puffin chicks.
You learn that they come out in the night
and they look for light,
moonlight in their instinct.
But they have no idea, is
it moonlight, traffic light,
a car light or garage
light, whatever it is,
they say light is light, let's go for it.
So they fly, then they stand
in the middle of the road
seeking two moon, hit by a car.
My wife Elfie and myself, we
just thought let's do something
and we did it.
I put this on the trees and
on the sign on the roads
that people know in the night
where can we deliver the Puffins
and where are the headquarters.
And then I put this one here,
they are illuminator for the cars.
You can put them on the car.
You need always a short
good name of doing something
and Puffin Patrol says everything.
Puffin Patrol, ding
dong, unnecessary light.
It's Puffin saving time, come in.
- Okay.
- So we started to buy gloves...
Here's my gloves.
Butterfly nets..
In the car I do have the net.
And the flashlight...
I do have the flashlight.
Elfie, are you ready?
- Yep.
- Good.
And Elfie and me went out the first time
to save the little birds.
So we go from the flashlight
from the left side
with a net from the right side.
The bird look at the flashlight,
I go from the left side,
and then we got it.
We put them then in a little cradle,
let's them here and
next day we let them go.
We drove from nine o'clock
to almost one o'clock in the night.
My smart wife told me,
Juergen, there's not enough.
We should not do this alone.
We should bring in some people.
And then it started.
It's 10 o'clock.
It depends every day how many we saving.
It could be 10, it could be 20.
Every night out, we put
them then in a little cradle
and then the next
morning, they're released.
Driving around, you're walking around,
low years 100, sometimes
800, 900 every night.
Driving one o'clock to two o'clock
and people were knocking on my door
and bringing birds in front of the door.
It's Puffin saving time.
Driving around, walking around.
I'm saying we saved over
a total more than 10,000.
Sometimes the whole
shed was full of birds.
It's Puffin saving time.
Every night.
Wait, wait, wait.
Nine to 11, and 11 to 12.
It's Puffin saving time.
Every night.
- [Woman] Puffin Patrol.
- Yes.
Then it came to our mind...
Wait, wait, wait.
It's too much, too big
for me and for us alone.
We were so happy that
we have now this spread
to Canadian Park and Wilderness Society,
and they decided to take
over the Puffin Patrol
as their issue.
- I don't think we can
ever fill Juergen's shoes.
So thank you for coming out.
When you have a program like this,
you start to find out in your community
who is conservation-minded,
who maybe they feel that
this is isn't an issue.
My name is Suzanne Dooley.
I'm with the Canadian Parks
and Wilderness Society.
We help coordinate and
facilitate this program.
To this day even now it seems
to be a very good news story.
Still there is a bit
of opposition as well.
We can't please everybody
but I know there is
a lot of opposition within the community
for and against like every project.
Some of our core volunteers that we had,
they see that and they
feel that as well too.
(radio static)
- [Presenter] Sometimes the
province makes the national news
for all the wrong reasons.
That was the case last week
in what is an ironic twist.
Witless Bay did indeed
make the national news
because of what looked like an effort
to silence the citizens on social media.
Witless Bay town council
had unanimously passed
a motion to look into retaining
independent criminal lawyer
to review a recent
social media accusations
against the current town council.
That didn't sit very well with Lorna Yard
who has been embroiled in a battle
with council over the
development of Ragged Beach.
Lorna joins me live in the studios.
Nice to see you, Lorna.
(laughing)
- My reputation in town, well.
I probably wouldn't want to imagine that.
But I don't know.
I just have to think about
that one for a second.
I am surprised by that question.
- I think Lorna wouldn't
describe herself as an activist.
- Lorna is very much involved
in the local community
because she's a fighter.
And she fights for the environmental.
- And I know that she is
one of the strong opponents
of the Ragged Beach group and
actually has a Facebook page.
- She runs the Ragged Beach Newsline,
which is all the news
about what's going on
and so forth.
- [Lorna] I have this
streak in me where I just,
I do stand up for things I believe in.
And so I never really get involved
in the Puffin Patrol too much
until the Ragged Beach threat happened.
(loud horn blowing)
So Ragged Beach is a dark coast right now.
There are no houses, there
is no light pollution.
And it is directly across
from the Ecological Reserve.
And it would never occur to
us to build a house there.
Because if you put in a
development on the coastline
I believe and many of us believe
it will be absolutely
catastrophic for the reserve.
But when you get people
coming in from outside
they just view a piece of land and say,
wow, this is amazing, I
would like to live here.
And so we have a group of
people fighting so hard
for what we see as the benefits
of protecting our environment
and protecting the Puffins,
and then we have people who
are really just concerned
with profit and monetizing coastlines.
- Oh, there's some berries.
Not quite ripe but
some are more than others.
So my name is AnnMarie Churchill.
I'm a landowner here in
the Ragged Beach area
and a Newfoundlander.
Yeah, so I grew up in Newfoundland.
and I grew up about 30 minutes from here
in the city of St. Johns.
And so when we came back
we just really wanted to be
close to the ocean and nature.
So that's how we ended up here.
We actually were hiking here one day
and looked it up when we got home
and there was land for sale.
We were told from the very beginning
there'll be a group there
who are going to oppose you.
They've opposed in the
past to anyone who's tried
to develop in this area
because they don't want
any houses down here.
But it's private property.
So we thought, okay,
well, we'll deal with it.
What do we need to do to make this okay?
Like what do you want?
And they said, we're
not here to negotiate,
we're here to stop you.
We want no development down here.
- When the Churchill's
put in their application
in 2010 to have that re-zoned,
at the time there was just a
collective scream of outrage
from the province, from the world.
And so this right here is Ragged Beach.
So you can see that
this is directly across.
Now here you'll see, this is Witless Bay,
and here you'll see this
subdivision back here.
So if you look at this subdivision
and you look at Ragged Beach,
you can see how close Ragged Beach is.
And you just look straight
out, you're looking straight
at the Witless Bay Ecological Reserve.
The island is directly across from it.
We live in a town of 1,200 people,
and our town council
got over 1,400 letters
against re-zoning that area.
They got 11 in support.
I have here a letter from Billmont Vicky.
Bill, he is a seabird biologist.
He's known the world over
that of all the ecological
seabird reserves
in Newfoundland and Labrador,
the Witless Bay Ecological Reserve
is the one in closest proximity
to coastal communities
and is the one most at risk
to human activities and development.
This is a letter from a descendant
of a Witless Bay resident.
This is a man who lives in New York.
A subdivision with more to come
and the most achingly
beautiful stretch of coastline
in Newfoundland.
Beautiful...
Not just because our eyes tell us so
but because our hearts do as well.
And those letters were just ignored.
Our provincial government ignored 'em.
And that's when the war
in this town started.
- [Woman] Good evening, everyone.
We have a long agenda
tonight, so you'll have to
just bear with me.
Okay, good evening.
- [Man] I'd like to take
the time to appoint board
to concern legal matters of town.
And I'd like to pass the motion.
These are concerns and
motions that I want to put...
(banging)
I require a second, do I have a seconder?
Do I have a seconder?
- Council Gary.
Excuse me.
- [Man] Do I have a seconder?
- [Woman] Sit down, please.
- Do I have a seconder?
- You're out of order.
- [Man] Council, with recommendations...
(mumbled shouting)
(soft instrumental music)
- [Lorna] Local town council
here does not subscribe to
issues of environmentalism
or sustaining your natural assets.
Our local council, their
mandate is development,
big development, big business,
that's their mandate.
Where there's more development
there's more lights.
And so we want to protect Ragged Beach.
- There are subdivisions in Witless Bay
as there are in all communities,
and I think when you start
new projects or whatever
you look back and say I
wish I had done something
a little bit different.
Clear cutting maybe in a
couple of the divisions here
or subdivisions may have been excessive.
But there is something to be said
for the private land owners that live
within that line of fire.
Who am I to say that they can't build?
And I'm an individual resident;
I'm not speaking for the council.
So yeah, I mean, I wouldn't
speak against them.
- I think it's insane that it seems to me
any reasonable person that
would walk down on that beach
and say let's put up some houses has got
something wrong with their thinking.
- I was shocked the first
time they called us developer.
And I think this group
know that that's a word
that gets people so they've used it,
they've called us "the developers."
No, we're land owners,
that's what I call me.
I'm a land owner, and I
want a house on my land.
I would say absolutely it's not a story
of development versus environment.
I think it is a story of
legitimate environmental causes
being hijacked to stop
some private land owners
in a small area Newfoundland
from using their land.
Their argument is if we put a house here
then we're adding lighting
and we're adding development to the area.
And my argument is that Newfoundlanders
have always built along the shoreline,
but it can be done respectfully.
In this town, people have
built lots of development.
But what we've done here
is 1,000 times different.
We didn't clear cut.
At the most we get a gazebo
or a house for our boys,
that's it.
I don't want subdivisions;
I don't want hotels. I want
peace. I feel I'm an environmentalist,
so I've had to question myself,
is this going to hurt the birds?
I don't believe one house is.
- This is where I do all my thinking.
This is where I come when I'm
feeling a bit stressed.
- [AnnMarie] The Puffins
have been hijacked.
Like I used to love the Puffin cause,
now I hear it and I almost get nauseated
because I know it's been hijacked
by people who know how to do it,
who are good marketers,
who are good sellers,
who do use social media.
So we have been vilified.
This has been put on Facebook,
that we're horrible people
and they spin something
to get their own way.
(buzzing)
- [Man] There's always in
small towns personal conflicts,
and usually they settle
it over a period of time.
But right now because of
social media and Facebook,
there seems to be quite a lot of texting
and tweeting going on.
- [AnnMarie] The scary part is that
that amplification is dangerous.
Like someone said, oh,
they don't own that land.
We'll burn down their gazebo,
and I worry about that
because if you get people who
don't think things through
or may not be stable, that could happen.
Like I think there could
be real consequences,
and I've said if this continues to go on,
somebody's going to get hurt.
- You know, I haven't
always acted honorably
and their have been times when frustration
and stress got to me.
Puffins can't speak for themselves.
Rocks and beaches can't
speak for themselves.
And whether not my head's
screwed on straight,
it's up for debate, but
my intentions are true.
So we're going back,
we're driving down
Gallus Cove Road here now
in Witless Bay.
We're going to go down to Ragged Beach.
It's at the very end of this road.
I always draw my strength and my comfort
from Ragged Beach.
So that's why I feel so strongly.
So we're coming here a lot in the fall
and generally in the off season.
But during the summer, not so much anymore
just because of the whole
situation surrounding us.
- [AnnMarie] I can't stay
reasonable and rational,
and I don't want to lose control.
I don't want to be upset
and angry all the time.
I want to be reasonable,
and I want to understand
where they're coming from.
So my fantasy is we'll work together,
but I don't think that will happen.
- So as you can see,
we're right at the feet
of the ecological reserve.
We're directly across from it.
So, our position is that if
you put development in here
I mean it's going to be
shining right at the reserve.
And we're already facing
a lot of challenges.
- [Man] You can all come out there.
- Izzy.
- You must be Lorna.
- Uh oh.
- Hi, I'm AnnMarie.
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm the person that you
love to hate all the time.
- I don't hate you.
- Well some of the personal stuff man...
- We agree to dis..
- Holy cow.
Is pretty wild when you don't know us
and have never met us.
- We didn't start the fire.
- A bit surprising.
Oh well, we got mad and it went personal
so I'm just saying you don't know us.
So it'd be great to get to
know each other sometime
so you actually...
- Well, you know, when you bought the land
you knew you couldn't build here.
- That's not true.
- I have a quote in a
newspaper that you said that.
- I have, we have approval
and principle from the land.
We had a lawyer investigate.
And you've written that you even saw
we had the approval and principle.
So that's beside the point at this point.
I have asked environmentalists,
one house up here as far
away as we've offered to be
give another 100 feet from the trail,
will that have any impact on the birds
and the answer was,
three houses in an environmental enclave
will not hurt the birds whatsoever.
- That's great.
- You can't tell me
that one house back here
with hooded lights,
environmentally sensitive,
is hurting the Puffins.
I think what you're doing is
your hijacking the Puffins
and the East coast Trail to keep this land
for your private crap.
- So you're related..
So your teaming up with Michelle.
That's why she flipped out 'cause she's...
- Who's Michelle?
This is what you do.
You do all this personal stuff.
I don't even know who Michelle is.
I have no idea
who you're talking about.
- Anyway.
- But you just said that
and tomorrow you'll have on Facebook
that we're somehow in with
someone doing something weird.
You guys have given nothing...
- You have gone to meetings,
You have screamed at people,
- We have tried everything.
- You harassed at me.
- Because...
- I sat in a courtroom with you..
- Lorna, please don't, please
don't do that in my face.
- I sat in a courtroom when you made fun
of a disabled senior citizen.
- Actually I'm not even going
answer that, that's not true.
- I heard you behind me laughing at him.
- That is absolutely not true.
- I heard you.
- We didn't even know
who was on the stand.
- I heard you
back there laughing.
- Lorna you have no idea
what we're talking about.
That's what I mean, what you do,
instead of the facts, you go personal
and you try to destroy people,
but we're not willing to
give up our land over it yet.
- It's not me, it's the town.
Nobody wants this...
- You just did it
about 10 times here,
- Nobody wants
this area developed.
- where I try to talk
and you start attacking me.
- It's not me.
- But you're the one doing this attacking.
This isn't rational, it's not a good...
- How am I attacking you now
when I'm telling you you can use your land
as you've always used
it, as it was designated.
You have no access, and
that's just the facts.
- I'm sorry it doesn't get
any better than that Lorna.
- Come on Iz.
(banging and soft violin music)
- [Juergen] I think this is
a very, very important place
for nature and for the animals.
But as always, when you're in the middle
of the eye of a cyclone, you're
not seeing the whole thing.
- [Woman] So it's something
worth fighting for?
- Something worth dying for, almost.
They think that they're going to wear
the people who want to preserve that down.
It's not going to happen.
It's a battle for me
that's not going to end.
And I don't think it's going to end
for a lot of other people.
- I think when you have controversy,
there'll always be a side of
it that's sensationalized.
I would hope that we
can find a common ground
for all groups that have concerns,
that someday soon we can
get those concerns out
and discuss them and
come to terms with them.
- [Lorna] I have missed a lot
personally and there's times
it's been really, really tough
to the point where you
know, I had episodes
of really severe depression
and there were times when
I just said to myself
and everybody else, I'm done, I'm done,
and you just come back.
But you know, there's also been
really amazing things, too.
Friendships have been made.
But at the end of the
day it's not about me.
It's about Ragged Beach;
it's about Puffins;
it's about wildlife; it's
about this spectacular reserve;
that's what it's about.
- [AnnMarie] I don't know, I
mean maybe I'll change my mind.
Maybe they will push us out of here
but I would feel bad about that.
I feel like we need to hold our ground
but try to keep it civilized.
I talk to people more,
but I'm trying to be helpful about it,
let people know the truth
and ignore social media.
I don't know where to go with that.
So I kind of have some
hope if we could hold out.
- [Juergen] The ecological
system is so sensitive here;
it is all here.
It's really here; you can
feel it, you can see it.
But we're there, Puffin Patrol,
and all the organization,
we try to protect them.
And it's growing, it's doing well.
- [Woman] What's your dream situation
for how this all ends up?
- Let me quote Jack Nicholson.
He told me Juergen, in a perfect world,
everything would be really perfect.
But we're not in a perfect world.
So what can I do, what can I change?
Of course, I do want to
stop the Puffin Patrol.
Of course I would not see
any dead birds anymore.
Of course, I would like
to have people respect
and think like this.
But the world isn't though.
It is as it is, so.
(buzzing)
(mooing)